Over the course of ten years, numerous storylines,
and countless changes, The Walking Dead probably
couldn't help but leave behind a bunch of
loose ends.
Here's a look at some of the major burning
questions that the series has yet to answer.
We last see a critically wounded Rick in season
9, injuring himself in a heroic attempt to
save his friends and loved ones from a massive
herd of Walkers.
What the other survivors don't know is that
Rick just barely survives his act of self-sacrifice,
and is rescued by the mysterious Anne.
Anne's allies gather the pair into a helicopter
to fly off to parts unknown, after which the
show jumps forward years later — with no
sign of Rick in the interim as far as the
other protagonists are concerned.
In season 10, Michonne discovers evidence
on a grounded military boat that Rick may
have survived the ordeal — among a host
of scavenged goods, she finds his boots and
cell phone, along with a log entry that suggests
he may be alive and is potentially in New
Jersey.
She sets off to find him.
Now, we know a few things about the mysterious
group who took Rick — the helicopter he
left in belongs to the Civic Republic Military.
That group is advanced, militaristic, and
a part of the Alliance of the Three, the group
of fortified partner cities which we've learned
more about in the Walking Dead's spinoffs.
So while we have a general idea of where Rick's
journey has taken him, the details of what
his life has been like since his departure
are still very vague, and we have no idea
what the intervening years have done for Rick's
circumstances or his character.
It seems we'll find out in the Rick-centric
movies that continue his story.
In the years since Rick's disappearance and
murky season 9 fate, fan favorite Michonne
has become the leader of the Alexandria Safe
Zone as well as the adoptive mother of Judith
Grimes.
We last see her in the episode "What We Become"
as she sets off north upon her discovery that
Rick may be alive, determined to discover
the fate of the man she still loves.
"What We Become" has been confirmed as being
the last appearance of the character on The
Walking Dead, so we are unlikely to discover
the answer to Michonne's fate within the show
as it wraps up its final story arcs.
This is obviously an unhappy end for fans
of the series, as Michonne is a pivotal and
well-loved character.
So... what will become of her?
Despite the character's absence from the rest
of the series, Michonne would be a natural
fit to return in the Rick-centric films, so
fans can probably expect a resolution to her
story whenever those start rolling out.
Another mystery concerns the fate of Eugene's
group, who are last seen captured by a cadre
of mysterious armed soldiers at the end of
season 10, episode 16.
The show hasn't revealed who these soldiers
are yet, but the scene is a note-perfect recreation
of a sequence in the comic books that marks
the debut of the massive community known as
the Commonwealth.
In the comics, the Commonwealth are a large,
well-organized network of communities that
attempt to "restart civilization" following
the devastation of the zombie plague.
It seems safe to assume that the attack is
our first introduction to the group, but the
show has deviated from the books that inspire
it before — until The Walking Dead tells
us outright who these people are, there's
no way of knowing for sure.
“Charleston, West Virginia.
Southern railyards, about a mile south of
the Kanawha River.
One week, can you be there?”
When Eugene sets out to meet the mysterious
Stephanie, he approaches his meeting from
a hopeful place.
After a long history of unrequited feelings
for Rosita, Eugene is understandably happy
at the idea of a potential romance with this
mysterious woman he sets out to meet for the
first time.
When he instead encounters an unexpected trap
at the intended meeting, he has to be suspicious.
Is Stephanie intentionally setting Eugene
up for a trap?
Or is it a well-intentioned meetup that's
intercepted in ways she can't control?
From Eugene's perspective, there could be
any number of explanations.
The comic books do show that Stephanie has
a connection to the Commonwealth, the group
whose white-armored soldiers trap and capture
Eugene and company, yet eventually she and
Eugene do start a relationship despite this
frightening experience.
The show's take on this relationship could
go in an entirely different direction.
Either way, Eugene's plans for romance have
hit at least a pretty major snag.
Two major series events — Rick's season
9 departure and Eugene's season 10 capture
— set us up for two major new civilizations
in the world of The Walking Dead in the Commonwealth
and the Civic Republic.
What does the existence of these groups mean
for the future of the show, and what is their
relationship to each other?
The Civic Republic is an advanced authoritarian
society and part of the Alliance of the Three,
an allied network of fortified cities including
Omaha, Nebraska; Portland, Oregon; and the
Civic Republic itself, which is geographically
around Pennsylvania.
It boasts 200,000 citizens and stands as the
largest civilization in the show world to
date.
The Commonwealth is an Ohio-based network
of communities with around 50,000 citizens
and its own well-organized standing army.
It's a central civilization in the comics,
and as such there's much more available information
on it.
It's a thoroughly hierarchical class system,
running in practice like a feudal monarchy
where people are locked into the jobs they
had before the apocalypse.
While the two organizations are distinct and
should have strong roles in the future of
the show, we don't know what their relationships
to each other are.
As two of the largest civilizations we've
seen so far, each with large, technologically
advanced militaries, they're all but certain
to at least know about each other.
At the same time, the Commonwealth of the
comics isn't a member of the Alliance of the
Three, since the latter group isn't a part
of the comic book storyline.
How are these two organizations connected,
if they are at all?
The future of the show and its world may lie
in the relationships between these societies
— we just don't know yet what they are yet.
Late in season 10, we see the introduction
of a mysterious masked warrior alongside Maggie.
Wielding dual curved blades, he's first seen
during a rescue of Gabriel, who's barricaded
in a hospital that's being besieged by a group
of Whisperers.
The Whisperers barge in and easily overtake
Gabriel.
It seems as though all is lost before the
masked warrior enters and effortlessly slaughters
the attacking Whisperers, the last of which
is taken out by Maggie.
The only clue we have to his identity is her
cryptic line of introduction, which isn't
very specific.
"It's okay.
He's with me."
We know a few things from this brief encounter:
the masked survivor is a he, a skilled warrior,
and Maggie clearly trusts him.
Other than those sparse details, we have yet
to learn much of anything about who's under
the mask, what his relation to Maggie is,
or... anything else about him, really.
Hopefully we'll be seeing a lot more of him
— and getting more answers — in future
episodes.
Virgil, first introduced in season 10, is
still a very mysterious character.
We first encounter him as a researcher in
the capture of Oceanside, one who promises
Michonne a weapon that will help against the
Whisperers.
Virgil accompanies Michonne on the excursion
that marks her major discovery of Rick's apparent
survival, leading to her own subsequent departure
from the show.
He betrays her, trapping and drugging her
and causing her to have a series of disturbing
hallucinations.
That betrayal serves as a prelude to the discovery
that Virgil has also been keeping his coworkers
captive for quite some time.
She overpowers him, and when Michonne discovers
Rick may be alive, she lets Virgil live and
sets off on her journey.
When Michonne leaves Virgil, she seems to
see some good in him despite his treachery
and a history of having done some bad things.
Is he trustworthy?
If not, Connie is certainly in jeopardy.
Her fate, and the response of Daryl and others,
remains mysterious.
Negan's free.
Our introduction to Negan comes when he's
the vicious leader of the Saviors, a group
who describe themselves as bringing civilization
and order back to the world — albeit at
a terribly steep cost.
“Whatever you do, no matter what, you don’t
mess with the new world order.”
Every community they encounter is subjected
to their rule, until a coalition of the Alexandria
Safe Zone, Hilltop Colony, the Kingdom, and
Oceanside break their power.
Until that time, Negan demands absolute loyalty,
often killing a member of a rebellious group
to reinforce his rule and subjugate those
he conquers.
Early on, in an effort to break the will of
Rick and his group, Negan brutally kills Abraham
and Glenn with his barbed-wire-wrapped baseball
bat, Lucille.
This leaves Maggie, Glenn's wife, tragically
widowed.
Following the defeat of Negan's Saviors, Maggie
is understandably angry at Rick's decision
to spare Negan's life.
Years later, Negan seems by all accounts to
be a changed man, killing Alpha on Carol's
behalf and actively working to prove his loyalty
to Daryl.
It seems at this juncture that Negan's years-long
change of heart is real... and he's no longer
in prison.
What will Maggie do when she finds this brutal
ex-ruler, the man who killed Glenn, is freely
out and about?
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.